les inondations ont fait des ravages
[Musique]
on a fait ça pour traverser le 4 jaunes
fois c'est lola la démarche sur la
pointe des orteils pour le chef comme ça
la maison de jesse et marianne n'était
pas en zone inondable et pourtant le
premier soir on est descendant à bord il
y avait 2 pouces d'eau dans les jambes
en effet ma fille dormait et entouré
d'autres
tout ça vient soit on comprenait pas
douter à venelles où elle écoute la
panique totale
même les enfants on dirait qu'ils sont
pas trop planète mongole jouait dans
l'aude comme les forces qui venait me
chercher à la maison les premières
semaines seront traversait plus en
voiture
des chansons il était heureux qu'ils
aient réalise pour puis maintenant à
l'école les problèmes la garderie celles
fournies
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
bon
on